[Musique]
comment ça va après la guerre enfin les
jours heureux pour le président qui veut
incarner chaque étape du déconfinement
le 9 juin prochain place à la troisième
phase du déconfinement en ce moment avec
une intensité grave sur Tik Tok il
intervient aussi régulièrement et avant
chaque vidéo il a tendance à rappeler à
sa jeune cible attention qui ne va pas
leur prendre beaucoup de temps
on prend 30 secondes de votre temps que
vous soyez ciné musée roman manga jeux
vidéo théâtre métal tout seul à la fois
nous avons créé pour vous le Pass
Culture la culture ne guérit pas du tout
de la bêtise mais Proust oui si vous
êtes un connard et que vous lisez
Baudelaire vous restez un connard qui
aime Baudelaire
mais si vous êtes un connard et que vous
êtes touché par Proust vous êtes un peu
moins connard il n'hésite pas aussi de
manière inopinée à intervenir dans les
commentaires sur Tik Tok d’influenceurs
vedettes qui sont suivis par des
millions de personnes et là il y a
vraiment un effet surprise qui est
toujours garanti lorsque le Président
vous parle on écoute bonjour monsieur le
Président oui c'est vraiment Emmanuel
Macron a commenté mon Tik Tok je suis
choqué du coup
ce portable là est-ce qu'on capte ici
non il n'y a pas du tout de réseau ici
non on capte pas je l'utilise seulement
pour écouter de la musique et des chants
mais là en plus il est complètement
déchargé alors je peux rien en faire la
vie c'est plus marrant c'est moi
désespérant en chantant écoutez écoutez
je mélange mes fantasmes et BPN voilà
bon je mets un billet sur la tête de
celui qui fera la tête ce con d'Éric
Zemmour voilà ce qui l'a dit également
la France un pays d'escrocs ils ont volé
nos œuvres d'art les ont mis dans leur
expo c'est une de ses chansons qui
s'adaptive de Marianne la mégère devenue
ma marâtre défavorable à mes gènes
je préfère
tout ce qui chante faux c'est pour lui
c'est pas pour moi je suis l'ennemi de
ma grande je suis l'ennemi de Ménard de
Marion
de la République de fille
j'ai arrêté Paname africaine
chez moi
c'est excité sur nous là ça ne va pas
ménager la vieille non ce sont eux les
assassins ceux qui depuis un an et demi
nous foutent dans des prisons jouer avec
nos nerfs joue avec nous joue avec nos
enfants qui aujourd'hui veulent faire
vacciner nos enfants qui aujourd'hui
nous foutent des masques à longueur de
journée qui aujourd'hui nous
emprisonnent qui aujourd'hui nous
empêche de vivre qui aujourd'hui nous
empêche de voir nos grands-parents qui
aujourd'hui nous empêche de vivre notre
propre vie
il y a aussi il faut dire un truc de
dingue là c'est le silence
vraiment
on lui a demandé si vous voulez faire
vacciner ses enfants il a dit non j'ai
vu ça juste avant de venir vous n'avez
ok
correctement ok
de respect pour vous l'intelligence
artificielle garder la pour vous allez
allez pourquoi vous vivez en Belgique
aujourd'hui c'est pour vous impose et
vous Stéphanie vous êtes en train de
passer votre cap de pâtissière je suis
en reconversion professionnelle
pour les financiers je suppose
[Musique]
elle était très belle
je n'ai jamais vu ça
personne n'a des cheveux qui poussent
sur les bras comme sur la tête
[Rires]
si je raconte aux autres que j'ai vu des
poils comme ça sur les bras d'un homme
personne ne me croira c'est incroyable
non je peux vraiment pas leur raconter
ça le bronzage du périnée les jambes en
l'air et le derrière face au soleil des
adeptes de yoga tentent de populariser
cette pratique mais aux Etats-Unis il y
a quelques années à les écouter les
vertus seraient nombreuses meilleur
absorption de la vitamine D diminution
du stress et libido-bofix entre autres
la pratique marginale inquiète tout de
même des dermatologues exposer ainsi son
intimité peut-être très dangereux en cas
de coup de soleil
[Musique]
tu dois pas te laisser souvent ma belle
je fais chier les jambes sur les images
captées par un patient on voit quelques
hommes assis dans cette salle d'attente
et face à eux en hauteur un écran qui
diffuse un film dont le scénario est
assez basique une histoire d'amour très
intense et fusionnelle pour le dire
simplement et donc c'est patients qui
font mine de ne pas vraiment regarder
tout en jetant des petits coups d'oeil
aucun ne semble pressé d'aller prévenir
le personnel de l'hôpital qui mettra 20
minutes à se rendre compte qu'un film
pour adulte est diffusé dans la salle
d'attente cette fois 69 mais comment on
fait 69 et ben le Renardo va vous le
montrer par ma voix
9 - 1,8
x 8 64 + 569
x 7 483 on entend les rires aiguilles à
je sais pas moi je vois vraiment pas
pourquoi non
posez pas des questions comme ça il y en
a un qui a pris des risques c'est
également fils regardez ces images lui
il a pris les risques face à Rogers
Federer pourquoi une fois deux fois
c'était pour rigoler on sait pas s'il a
rigolé jusqu'au bout Roger en tout cas
il est mort de rire là je vise
l'Australie très bien
[Musique]
et ça je te l'ai dit aussi c'est quoi ce
pays
les États-Unis non c'est raté
et la seule bonne raison c'est que
Claire chazalathan pour passage des arts
Aurélien pour ça le notre spectateur
Merci à VOUS
ciao c'est trop tard